sorted and packaged ready to be enjoyed
as a healthy snack or used in various
culinary Creations the Peaches on the
other hand are sorted by size and
quality ensuring that only the best make
it to the market at the market the
vibrant colors of the peanuts and
peaches catch the eye of eager customers
the farmers proudly display their
produce sharing their hard work and
dedication with the world from roasted
peanuts to Peach pies there's something
for everyone to enjoy so next time you
bite into a delicious peanut or Savor
the sweet nness of a peach remember the
journey it took to reach your plate from
the fields to the market these fruits
are a testament to the hard work and
passion of our Farmers join us as we
celebrate the harvest season and support
our local farmers together let's enjoy
the fruits of their labor and Savor the
Flavors of Nature's Bounty